KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on-site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I have with me Daniel.
He is the founder
of Artisan Ethos.
Daniel, thank you for joining.
DANIEL KATZ: Thank
you for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: So tell us,
what is Artisan Ethos?
DANIEL KATZ: So
Artisan Ethos is like
an online, curated gallery.
Basically, we gather
the best artisan
craftspeople from
all around the world
and sell their products
on an e-commerce platform.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
So you're going
directly to artisans?
DANIEL KATZ: Right.
KORY JEFFREY: You're
kind of cutting out
the broker in the middle.
What's the quality of stuff
that you can get there?
DANIEL KATZ: So, basically,
it's-- I mean, as an example,
it would be something like
hair masks, fur, leather bags.
The best English
silverware makers,
the best Japanese
ironware makers, the best
Japanese kimono makers.
And a lot of the stuff that
they're going to be making
are very modern things.
But everything is
the highest quality.
So you'll get
hand-stitched leather bags
from the best French calfskin.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
How does that work?
How do you find your artists?
DANIEL KATZ: So, a lot of
it is just about networking.
It's going out and looking.
We have partners all
around the world.
So somebody in France
and Italy and Japan,
they speak the local language.
They have connections
there with these people.
And they go and source
these products, basically.
And I basically curate these
products for this website.
KORY JEFFREY: So
the artisans love it
because it's another opportunity
for them to sell their goods,
and consumers love it because
it's much cheaper for them
to buy.
DANIEL KATZ: Exactly.
And the artisans get paid a lot
more than, maybe, a designer
would pay them.
KORY JEFFREY: Great.
DANIEL KATZ: Yeah,
the best part of it
is that these artisans
don't have an outlet.
So they usually sell for their
own local, domestic market.
Maybe a few boutiques in
that country would sell it.
They don't have a world market.
They don't have a place
where they can actually
sell these crafts.
KORY JEFFREY: So
how do you maintain
that quality is high level?
How do you ensure that
the artisans that you get
are the artisans?
Is a closed network,
and it's hard to get in?
DANIEL KATZ: Yeah.
First of all, it's
basically like a trial.
And they have to
send me a sample so I
can see that it is the best.
Plus, when I sell
the products, I'm
not just selling the product.
I'm selling the craftsperson
who made the product for you.
So you can see their profile.
You can see their history.
You can see the
history of the craft.
You see photos and
videos of them actually
producing the craft, producing
it with different steps.
So you don't really get
that with something you buy.
You get to know your maker.
And that person is
actually making it for you.
KORY JEFFREY: Great.
That's very cool.
So where is the product today?
DANIEL KATZ: It's in beta.
There's a website,
artisanethos.com.
And I'm just basically
testing the market.
And I'm looking for investment,
which is kind of why I'm here.
I was hoping to find some
angels or seed funding.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure,
meet some people.
Have you had any
luck meeting people?
DANIEL KATZ: A few
people, but not many yet.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
Very cool.
Well, there's lots around.
So you have to find them.
So let's switch
gears a little bit.
Obviously, as you
walk around, there's
a whole bunch of technology
on display, a lot of people
in different areas.
Is there anything in particular,
besides the e-commerce market
that you're working in, that
particularly excites you?
DANIEL KATZ: Yeah, app
development in general,
which is kind of why I like
this organization you have,
Google Developers.
Just in general, UX UI
design really excites me.
And one of the other
reasons I'm here
is I was hoping to find an
app developer that would
be working with us, hopefully.
KORY JEFFREY: So looking for
some technical talent, as well?
DANIEL KATZ: Exactly, yeah.
Because right now everything's
through Squarespace.
And that's great
for the website,
but I want an app as well--
iOS and Android in the future.
KORY JEFFREY: Great.
Very cool.
I guess, a related question,
do you have a favorite Google
technology?
DANIEL KATZ: Yes, the
Google Translate app,
the one that uses the camera
to translate everything.
It's simple to use for
when you're traveling.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, for sure.
And obviously you do a
lot with the company.
It seems like magic, doesn't it?
You just kind of hold
it up, and it tells you.
That's awesome.
Well, thank you very
much for joining us.
DANIEL KATZ: Thank you.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
And thank you guys
for joining us.
We are on-site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]